PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Are
you migrating to Cloud?
What should you migrate first?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Cloud Migration 101,
where we share migration tips
and tricks.
I'm Priyanka.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: And I'm Kyle.
And in this episode,
we'll walk you
through the process of
choosing the first application
to migrate to Google Cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Let's say, today, I'm
the head of engineering at
Clow D Corp. We make automated
floodgates for water mills.
As you can imagine,
our infrastructure
is complicated with a large
number of applications,
and I'm not sure which
application to move first.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Well, let me
help demystify this process.
Let's start by seeing all of
your apps and what they are.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yes,
so here are all our apps.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Ah,
the first thing to do
is to group your
applications into categories.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All of
my single-tier applications,
multi-tier applications,
databases, and dev tools
are grouped together now.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Awesome.
Now we find one common example
in each category, something
that does a good
job of representing
the entire category.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
For this, we will
have to drill deeper into what
makes an app a good candidate
for being the first to migrate.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Exactly.
And there's a list of criteria
that I generally recommend.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right,
let's go through this list
then.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: A good
first application to migrate
should be something that's
typical of your existing
workloads but nothing
that's business-critical.
We want to use this application
to build a knowledge
base within our organization
around how to migrate
applications to the cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
For this reason,
we should not pick an app that
is extremely business-critical,
but we should also not
pick an app that is used,
say, a few times a year.
Try to find a balance of
moderately business-critical
application so it helps increase
the momentum of the migration.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Now,
the second criteria
is that we want an
application that's
managed by a central
team so it has support
and, ideally, has an application
owner who embraces innovation.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Picking
a high-performance team that
sits in the main office with a
proven history of implementing
modern dev practices,
DevOps, and SRE
can be a good candidate.
If these apps have leadership
sponsors and clear goals,
that would be perfect.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Now,
the third criteria
is that we want to try
and find something that's
relatively standalone with a
low number of network security
and application
dependencies and, also,
doesn't need any
code refactoring
to move to the cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Stateless
apps would be great,
because they don't require any
data migration, or an app that
only needs configuration
changes, but no code changes.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Next, the
data storage requirements
should be relatively small.
If your application has
petabytes of storage,
you probably shouldn't
use that as a first mover.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
This is mainly
because we don't want to
start off with an edge case
by picking an app that
is not representative
of most of the other apps.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: The
application should also not
be subjected to any complicated
compliance or licensing
challenges.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Make sure
the licensing terms are clear.
Check if the license allows
you to run the app in the cloud
or not.
You may also have specific
compliance requirements.
For example, in some
countries, the customer
has the right to decide
where to store their data.
KYLE MOSCHETTO:
For these reasons,
we recommend such apps
not be the first ones
that you migrate.
And last, but not least,
we want an application that
can afford a cutover window.
If the application has to
stay up 100% of the time,
it is not a great candidate for
your first mover application.
Your teams are going to be
learning with the first mover,
and we want to be able to
provide them a cushion, where
if they make a mistake, it's not
detrimental to your business.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Since an application,
like batch processing, can
tolerate a longer downtime
than the
customer-facing apps, it
makes sense to pick
batch processing
service over the
e-commerce apps,
assuming it meets
other criteria,
as we discussed earlier.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Now, let's try
and apply this to our
applications at Clow D Corp.
So here's a landscape
of applications.
We already grouped the
apps based on categories.
KYLE MOSCHETTO:
Among these apps,
what are some of your
high-performance teams?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
inventory, payment, SaaS
and mobile apps, document
database, SQL database,
and CI tools are some of
our high-performance apps.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: And
out of those, which
would require
refactoring or migration
has major dependencies
that it would require?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
SaaS and mobile apps,
along with SQL database,
have dependencies
and may require refactoring, but
others are fairly independent.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: OK, what
about serious edge cases?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: SQL
database is huge and also won't
lead to a ton of learning
that can apply to other apps,
except for, maybe, another
SQL database that is internal,
so that could be
a later migration.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Great.
Do any of these have
licensing concerns?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: No, but there
are some data compliance things
that we need to take care of
around users and data in EU
for our SaaS application, so
we cannot start with that.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: OK.
And which of these apps can
afford a decent cutover window?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: CI
tools and inventory service
can afford a cutover
window, for sure.
Payment service and
SQL database has
to be 100% available
all the time,
so those will be a no-go
for the first phase.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Well, with
that, you have the list of apps
that you want to migrate first.
Start with the inventory app.
Learn from that.
Apply it to the mobile app,
the CI tool, the SQL database,
and do that in sequence.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Remember,
it's really beneficial
to start small.
Move a very simple application
first, and learn a bunch
about how you're going to run
your larger and more complex
applications on Google Cloud.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: And by
using this approach,
you'll set your business up
for a successful migration
to Google Cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So today, we learned
how to decide what
to migrate first.
We started by grouping
our apps into categories
and then apply these
different categories
to make the right choice.
If you are in the
process of migration,
don't forget to
like and subscribe,
because we don't want you to
miss any episode of this Cloud
Migration 101 series.
[MUSIC PLAYING]